president Trump's personal attorney
Michael Cohen made an appearance in
court today briefly it was a significant
moment but the press focused on pornstar
stormy Daniels who made an appearance in
the gallery watch well Daniels got the
most attention today but obviously she's
a sideshow just another act in our
never-ending circus the real news came
at the hearing itself Michael Cohen was
forced to hand over a list of his
clients to a judge among those on the
list was our friend Sean Hannity in the
hour after hours judge Kimball would
ordered Hannity's identity revealed
even though Hannity had specifically
requested that his name remain private
which is his right a couple of hours ago
Sean issued the statement quote Michael
Cohen has never represented me in any
matter
I never retained him received an invoice
or paid legal fees I have occasionally
had brief discussions with him about
legal questions about which I wanted his
input and perspective and quote some
plans to address this more broadly in
just a bit on Fox but keep in mind that
sean hannity is a talk show host he's
not under investigation by anyone for
anything who he hires as a lawyer and
why is nobody's business no judge has a
right to violate his privacy or anybody
else's those used to be the rules but
the rules have changed they pointed the
Ruscha investigation you may have
figured out is not to find collusion
there was no collusion everybody knows
that everyone's always known that the
point is and was to hurt Trump and
anyone close to Trump by the way it's
working now maybe you hate Trump and
you're happy about that but what are the
rest of us losing in this process
attorney-client privilege no longer
means anything we learned that the other
day neither does privacy or public
reputation or fairness if Cowen's other
clients can be exposed by the left
solely to embarrass them what is the
next step exactly could you punish it
Trump a lie by I don't know revealing
his internet search history
what about someone's medical records
about a private conversation with a
priest or rabbi why not all of that will
no question and when it does the left
will chair because extremism and the
pursuit of Trump is no vice according to
them the question is do you really want
to live in a country like that who would